red sox starting pitcher
zach godley facing biggio led off last
night with a home run
and a ground ball to the right side to
get him started went away
well travis shaw thought he had left the
ballpark last night in the ninth inning
but mr verdugo had
another thought when he made a terrific
leaping catch up against the bullpen
fence
got him struck him out two gone yeah
just above the belt
that's actually a pretty good pitch to
hit right there and shaw just
right through it no contact at all
hernandez has been one of their best
hitters if not their best guys
2-2 to hernandez swung on and miss
struck him out
back-to-back case by godly chase
anderson making his toronto debut as
alex verdugo steps in
from the line the pitch a change-up
swing and a miss and verdugo goes down
swinging
ungone for vlad guerrero jr he's not the
first guy who's seen kind of dive
after those he lines that one benetendi
dives ahead
he made the catch boy that looked a lot
like the play he made
in houston in the alcs to end it what a
grab for ben and tendy
going all out into a superman dive that
is a spectacular grab for route number
two
2-1 none out for christian vasquez
threw into center field for a base hit
bogarts comes home he will score
this time a ground ball gets through and
the red sox lead it one to nothing
nicely done cross seam fastball up
don't get too many ground balls on high
fastballs but he finds a hole right up
the middle rbi base hit here
hey picks up his uh 11th rbi of the
season
with that basic that's a good two strike
hitting by vasquez
lead off man aboard for catcher danny
jansen
that's in there for strike three it's
kind of a big plate tonight
and janssen will go down and firing the
pitch one nothing red sox top of the
fourth and travis shaw will lead it off
against zach godley
ground ball that's fair and it's gobbled
up by morgan he flips on to godly
another outstanding play out of mitch
moore this guy
is amazing at first base he really is it
doesn't matter whether he's going to his
right his left
backhanded play saves the double
probably right there
gives a nice flip to the pitcher
covering and records the out
beautiful play by foreign
he's walked he's also grounded out to
the shortstop
swing the bat sharply and right into a
twin killing
side retired doubled up on a wicked line
drive in borland right there
to turn two blue jays starter chase
anderson went through three wilmer
fought got through two thirds of the
fourth then anthony k
took over and he'll start this fifth
inning clean here's the pitch of the
right-handed batting jose perazo one two
fastball inside corner strike three
called nothing peraza could do with that
tremendous pitching by anthony k his
first strikeout
officially in relief two away here in
the fifth lefty on lefty
devers here's a swag and a miss at a
fastball 96 over the outside corner
another impressive inning for anthony k
and a base hit into right field for
hernandez
up to second on the play goes shaw a
nice piece of hitting by
tay oscar he got a 3-1 fastball away
stays on it doesn't try to do too much
goes the other way and picks up another
he's got 14 hits now
he was robbed of a base hit on a diving
grab made in left field by ben and tindy
in his second inning runners on it first
and second
the 1-0 swing the ball rolled against
the ship base hit into right field
shaw hits the bag at third and it is up
the line and
valdez is throwing him out a great play
by vasquez
as he took it about five feet up the
third base line shaw tried to go around
him
and a nice move by christian vasquez to
reach around and tag it
richard at first
that one hooked shot into right on the
move pilar long run and he's got it oh
he took a hit
and down on his back he can slam
into some walls folks he's done it again
and amazingly he hung on to the baseball
he had it all sized up i mean he
barely had enough time to brace himself
that is a great catch
i mean this just knocks him down like a
punch boom
down he goes but he's able to get up
well i thought that was hooking down the
line he had a chance to get out of here
he snatches it
and has just enough time to to take the
sting out of that
almost knocked him out you think about
it look at that boom
he is feeling absolutely feel of two
outs and
bo buchet will be the batter 2-2
fastball swung on hitting the air to
center field
back goes bradley again this one's over
his head and he'll crash off the garage
door
into scorus grichik jansen gets held up
at third base
on rbi double by beau bechet has tied
this game and it's 1-1
here in the top of the seventh and
hernandez will climb in 1-4-3
toronto the man at every base with two
down and the o2
looked like he went he did that strike
three brazier does the job
he leaves him loaded toronto's tied it
one-one
wire batted once pinched hitting and his
2-2 is swung on
and missed terrific curveball from
anthony k
that's a good sign full count pitch half
swing on a slider did he go
no says first base umpire ryan adding
it's a lead-off walk for lourdes curiel
jr so now randall grichik one for three
had an infield hit that
got things started in the bottom of the
seventh
to right field and this ball is going to
get down
guriel will make the turn and come to
third
gritchik with a long single and it's
runners on the corners with only one out
and here's rowdy teles
looking to bring home the go-ahead run
and a ground ball weekly hit to the
right side
and all they will get is the out at
first in to score on the play is goriel
and the blue jays have taken the lead
how about that
and a 1-1 to jbj all popped up down the
left-field line towards the corner
guriel is there
he's got room makes the catch to finish
the ball game
a 1-2-3 save in the ninth for anthony
bass
and the blue jays stormed from behind
after trailing early
looking for offense a couple of
defensive miscues
they rally in the seventh to tie they
take the lead in the eighth
and they hold on for a 2-1 win tonight
at fenway park